This time we make sure that
the new recording label and
stop button stay in the correct
position and size, at all times.
Much like the original record button,
we need to add constraints to
these two interface elements.
First we have to think about what we
want, which is three UI elements,
one beneath the other,
centered on screen.
They should always be in the center,
regardless if we're running the app on
a small iPhone or the new iPad Pro.
We already have a recording button
centered on the main UI View
over our View Controller so
we can anchor the other two
views off the recording button.
Let's start with the recording label.
The recording label is this one
here that says tap to record.
With it selected, let's control drag
diagonally to the record button.
The menu that comes up is context
sensitive to the direction of the drag.
If you just do a straight up and down or
left to right drag, you only get
a subset of the constrained options.
With the shift key held down,
select vertical spacing and
centered horizontally,
then click add constraints.
This means that we want to maintain
the vertical spacing from the recording
button to this label, and
then we want to label to be centered
horizontally to the record button.
So how does auto layout know where
the label needs to be on screen?
It checks to see where the record
button is and placed this label,
based on that, using the two
constraints that you've just setup.
If you're remembering back to earlier,
how I mentioned that there
are two constraints needed for
each axis, two for the x and
two for the y, you're correct.
However the label, much like
the UIButton, has an intrinsic size.
So auto layout can figure
out the height and
width of the label based on the text and
font of the label.
So all we need to provide is where
to place it along the x and y-axis.
In other words, just one constraint for
the x and one constraint for the y.
Let's set up the constraints of the stop
recording button against the tap to
record label.
Once more, drag the agony from
to stop recording button to
the tap to record label.
With the shift key pressed down,
select vertical spacing and
center horizontally,
then click add constraints.
We should be able to see six
constraints under the constraints
section of the document outline.
Your number here inside these
constraints may vary a little bit from
20 to 21 to 23 and they may be a little
different than mine and that's ok.
They're based on where you placed
your UI elements in the storyboards
when you dragged them in.
Let's see if this worked.
Click run or press command R and
you should see the Pitch Perfect
app running on the iOS simulator.
Let's try different screen orientations
to see if they stay centered.
You can see here that they stay
center of the landscape and would see
the same if we switch to different
iOS simulators such as the iPad air.
We should see here, that our three
buttons are always centered on screen.
Remember it may seem frustrating now,
that's okay.
You're just learning and
this is likely one of the first
times you've tried auto layout.
Keep at it and
it'll become second nature in no time.